doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is filled with unexpected cameos
but one stood out in particular who is
this powerful hero keep watching to
discover the eye-opening and human
appearance in the multiverse of madness
warning spoilers ahead the last few
years of the marvel cinematic universe
have been crammed with crowd-pleasing
moments from captain america wielding
mjolnir in avengers end game to the
return of toby maguire and andrew
garfield in spider-man no way home
marvel studios seems to have figured out
an effective way of capitalizing on fan
speculation and nostalgia with truly
entertaining results and now that the
multiverse is well and truly on the
table audiences have come to expect the
unexpected this definitely works in the
favor of sam raimi's doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness since fans are
desperate to see who shows up from
across the marvel pantheon and the 2022
sequel doesn't disappoint as the
illuminati apprehends dr strange when he
arrives on earth 838 with america chavez
leading to a very satisfying set of
high-profile cameos
stephen strange
the illuminati will see you now yes it's
fan service but the cameos stick the
landing because they're not drawn out
across the entire movie marvel studios
keeps the surprise appearances contained
to that one universe as patrick stewart
reprises his role as x-men leader
professor x and hayley atwell once again
plays a live-action peggy carter one of
the most surprising members of the
council is reed richards also known as
mr fantastic of the fantastic four
played by none other than john krasinski
and to top it all off the cameo crew is
also joined by another legendary hero
black bolt played by anson mount last
seen in abc's and humans series the abc
series didn't do the team of heroes
justice as it tried to balance its big
ambitions with a tv budget and failed
hard at doing so you only need to look
at the special effects used in an
attempt to bring the juices tactile hair
to life to see why it's a shame because
it definitely had potential and the
performances were pretty good especially
from mount as black bolts thankfully
when black bolt shows up in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness the
film delivers a much more faithful
version of the inhuman king for starters
the film gives him his comic accurate
costume complete with metallic wings and
head fork rather than the limp leather
jacket from the tv series the film
redeems a character in what could be
read as a sneaky apology while also
surprising fans by killing him off as
quickly as he returns but it's such an
impressive death that no one is
complaining wonder maxum after scarlet
witch magically seals black bolt's mouth
shut after reed warns her that the
king's voice has the power to destroy
her giving her time to react and this
has disastrous consequences when the
inhuman tries to unleash his devastating
sonic shockwave it bounces back inside
his head and his skull explodes killing
him instantly it's a shame to see him
die so quickly but this is just one
version of reality in the multiverse and
there's nothing to say he can't come
back in the main earth 616 universe if
you're wondering why black bolt is so
important in the first place it's
because he's the king of the inhumans a
race of genetically altered super beings
who evolve thanks to terrigen mists the
process either kills them during the
chrysalis transformation or grants them
extraordinary powers unfortunately for
black bolt his powers mean that he can't
talk without unleashing a devastating
shockwave in fact he accidentally killed
his parents when he destroyed a cree
ship by shouting the wreckage fell on
the inhuman parliament killing most of
the council including his parents as if
that wasn't enough the shockwave also
had a deeply troubling effect on his
brother maximus the inhumans are one of
the largest factions in the marvel
universe alongside the avengers and the
x-men in the world of comics they've
clashed with the other heroes on a
number of occasions in stories like
civil war inhumans vs x-men and the
upcoming judgement day event however on
earth 838 it appears that all those
factions have struck an accord as
evidenced by black bolts participation
in the illuminati the inhumans team was
originally meant to get their own solo
movie in the mcu but those plans were
shuttered for a number of reasons and
the project was reshaped into a tv show
it'll be interesting to see whether
they'll eventually join the ranks of
earth's mightiest heroes in the main
earth 616 universe now that black bolt
has stepped onto the big screen
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
dr strange and the multiverse of madness
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you